there's a place of Russia's northernmost
point called the Tamir Peninsula it's
basically an Arctic and it's where
Russia has been quietly building a
secret new megaport but what's really
shocking is that this 110 billion dollar
project has stayed quiet for so long
considering just how big it is it's
gonna house over 400 000 workers in the
middle of literally nowhere so they've
had to build the infrastructure from
scratch we're talking highways two new
airports 15 Villages multiple Railways
and a brand new 500 mile long oil
pipeline they've even installed the
first Arctic fiber optic cable you heard
right Russia's Frozen Wasteland probably
has better internet than you the ports
golf was dug out for larger ships to
pass through just in time for a new
Fleet of 40 ice class vessels including
eight nuclear-powered icebreakers why is
Putin building a giant megaport in the
Arctic because right now there's a
secret race between Russia China and the
United States to conquer the Arctic the
polar ice caps are melting which
presents an opportunity like never
before from the first time in history
Humanity will have ready access to the
Arctic which means faster shipping lanes
untouched fishing stocks as well as
trillions of dollars in oil natural gas
and rare metals question is who's going
to conquer the Arctic first right now it
looks like it's gonna be poop
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the battle for the Arctic
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
like a digital marketer photographer
designer or even a writer and you're
looking to raise your prices then you
have to check out bloom.io Bloom is also
free so you're gonna want to stick
around bloom.il basically took all the
tools you typically have to duct tape
together to run your business like
docusignmoney.com typeform WordPress
stripe and put them all together into
the sleekest cleanest all-in-one
solution designed specifically for
Freelancers and small agencies website
you can build a beautiful one to
Showcase your work capture links
directly on your website and even allow
people to buy your services sign the
contract set up a retainer book A Time
all within bloom once you close a client
that's where the real game changer comes
in Bloom's client portal where you can
invite them to their own customized
client portal they can see the
deliverables you made they can chat with
you and most importantly they can see
your beautiful invoice and pay for it
right then and there with cash out memo
Zell PayPal and more this is a super
easy way to raise your rates because of
how professional it makes you look Bloom
also gives you different project
management workflows for different
Services you off offer email automations
lead management a super powerful
built-in calendar and so much more so
start making more money right now with
Bloom's free tier with the link below or
use code jtran for 30 off their premium
features pause the video and go to
bloom.iochem with code Jake Chan with
the link below you're not going to
regret it thanks to Blue for sponsoring
this video
in 2017 a Russian oil tanker became the
first shift across the Northern sea
route from China to Europe without
needing an icebreaker this cut the trip
from 48 days to just 19 days and since
the Arctic is expected to have ice-free
Summers as early as 2035. this Voyage
caught the whole world's attention as a
sign of things to come it was a game
changer see traditionally you would have
to go to the Panama and Suez canals to
ship stuff around the world but the
Panama and Suez have a reputation of
slowing Commerce down like in 2021 when
the Evergreen container ship got stuck
in the Suez and blocked all shipping
traffic for six days which caused a loss
of 6.9 billion dollars in international
trade for each day it was stuck but the
Arctic if you were able to transport
Goods to the Arctic it would change all
of that and give whatever country that
controls that route unparalleled wealth
and power that's why Russia plans to
ship 100 million tons of oil to the
Arctic each year by the time the Newport
is running at full capacity so even
though they suck more than 100 billion
dollars into the project it will be very
worth it
now a two percent increase in GDP
doesn't sound very impressive but when
you look at the numbers and realize that
a two percent increase in GDP would mean
Russia will make at least 30 billion US
dollars more each year than they were
making before you start to understand
why Putin is pushing for this so much
and this is just the beginning the
Arctic is going to make Russia insanely
rich and if the US doesn't catch up it's
gonna really shift the balance of power
around the world but faster shipping
lanes aren't the only source of wealth
that Arctic has to offer there are
untapped witches like Nico platinum and
rare earth metals needed to build
computers and other Tech buried within
the Arctic it's also believed to contain
almost a fourth of the world's
undiscovered fossil fuel supply which
would be worth at least 35 trillion
dollars in today's money and it's not
just Russia that's vying for power in
the Arctic
[Music]
it's gonna take more than just one
megaport to make the Northern sea route
into a functional shipping Lane several
smaller ports and stuff will also have
to be built along the way so to do this
Russia is enlisting the help of China
China is building a bunch of docks in
ports with Russia in the Arctic as part
of xinjiangping's belt and Road
initiative and this is just the latest
in China's efforts to gain power at
Arctic only a year after Russia's
record-breaking ice-free trip to Europe
China announced their Initiative for a
polar Silk Road and that China was
officially a near-arctic states which is
a reference to countries like Iran being
called near nuclear States this claim
definitely didn't cause any controversy
at all China even argued that the
world's Nations should take a
Cooperative friendly approach to sharing
Arctic Resources with one another and
that resources should be divided equally
among the world's population which would
conveniently mean that China gets 25 of
everything in the Arctic just by default
what a coincidence surprisingly no one
else seemed to support the idea but that
didn't stop China they've been doing
exploration missions and setting up
research bases in the Arctic for decades
they even bought a ukrainian-built
Icebreaker named the shui long or snow
dragon they've been using it to explore
conduct research and do surveillance on
their competitors they got a second
Icebreaker called the schweilong 2 in
2021 but that is far from what their
Arctic dreams end another goal of China
is to build a network of bases for both
economic and Military purposes such as
the three new airports they tried to
build in Greenland as well as an
abandoned Naval Base they tried to buy
there because Arctic shipping lace
wouldn't just mean better economic trip
for China it would also mean that their
military could get to the Atlantic Ocean
and many other parts of the world they
weren't able to before just like they
did this past August when Chinese
warships surprised the U.S Coast Guard
by showing off 50 miles off the Alaskan
Coast without warning but many of these
attempts to expand in the Arctic have
been shut down and when Russia's
northern border dominating so much of
the territory China knows that if they
want to get their slice of the Arctic
they're gonna have to play next with
Russia at least for the time being
because the old if you can beat them
join them strategy is much better for
China than being left out of the Arctic
entirely unfortunately for the United
States America is already a few years
behind in this race for the Arctic
[Music]
[Applause]
the US has had some issues keeping up
with the competition in the Arctic
simply because the idea is not very
popular in America remember when Trump
was president and he tried to buy
Greenland everyone thought it was an
insane idea the territory of Greenland
is actually owned by Denmark who wasn't
too thrilled by the idea everyone
thought he was joking and when it turned
out he was serious they just thought he
was crazy but as it turns out it wasn't
a completely random idea see the US
already has claims of their own in the
Arctic territory through the shipping
lanes they share with Canada along the
Northwest Passage as well as the massive
oil and gas reserves on the North Slope
of Alaska but there's a problem not only
are Russia and China building massive
projects for shipping and extracting
natural resources in the Arctic and
they're beefing up their military
presence in the region the US hasn't
really been doing anything to develop or
protect this territory Russia has
reopened at least 50 of Bin and Soviet
military bases on their northern border
as well as building big brand new ones
on top of that Russia has 16 deep water
ports and 13 air bases all protected by
long-range surface-to-air missiles while
the US military has exactly nothing in
the Arctic nothing at all see Russia
knows a warming Arctic means they're
incredibly massive 15 000 mile long
northern border is no longer safe they
can't count on all the ice snow and
dangerous weather to keep their enemies
out anymore and for the US that also
means that the North Slope of Alaska is
no longer safe either after all Russia's
only about 55 miles from U.S territory
and that's a risk that can go both ways
so the U.S has a lot of work to do in
order to up its game securing access to
territory like Greenland would be a
smart idea not only is it full of
Natural Resources but its territorial
Waters would be a big part of the
shipping lanes the U.S would need in
order to compete the US also desperately
needs a new Icebreaker fleets just
because the polar ice will be gone in
the summer doesn't mean winter travel
won't be an issue having Icebreaker
ships is a necessity it's why Russia has
a massive Fleet of their own they have
40 icebreakers in total including
nuclear-powered ones it's also why China
has trying to build its own fleets and
why other Arctic Nations like Canada
Finland Sweden they all have about six
or seven of their own icebreakers as
well but for its massive military and
navy the US barely has two and I mean
barely its heavy class Icebreaker called
The Polar Star was built in 1976 so it's
47 years old and can barely run anymore
without breaking down but instead of
being decommissioned after 30 years of
service the Coast Guard has had to keep
it running simply because we don't have
anything else the second Icebreaker is
only a medium class and after an engine
fire in 2020 it's been sitting on use of
waiting repairs so the US Arctic Fleet
is pretty sad and then there's the
problem of America not having an Arctic
military base this makes doing things
like keeping an eye on passing Chinese
warships a little bit difficult Trump
had a bunch of plans in the works to
change this like floating the idea of
buying Greenland ordering construction
of a new Fleet of icebreakers as well as
a series of military bases to be built
in the U.S Arctic territory him in
Congress even pushed the US military to
build a port to rival the mega what the
Russians were building but due to one
reason or another one by one these
projects were shut down
us is being left out in the cold
[Music]
[Applause]
surprisingly the Biden Administration
hasn't stopped paying attention to the
Arctic it didn't stop being an important
issue it just became one that couldn't
be discussed openly mostly out of the
fear of alienating people who had
concerns about protecting the
environments so rather than get caught
backpedaling or changing its mind the
White House quietly announced a new
strategy for the Arctic in October of
this year the public documents outlining
this strategy are super vague and don't
mention any specific projects but there
have been quite a few things starting up
again construction has continued on a
brand new Icebreaker the government is
looking to buy another privately owned
Icebreaker to add to its fleets granted
this is a far cry from the minimum of
six the Coast Guard says it needs in
order to function it is a start the
Department of Defense also just
announced they're establishing a
research center in Anchorage Alaska and
the US government has also issued a
record-breaking number of oil drilling
permits on public lands including a
million Acres just off the Alaskan Coast
again it's not much but it is a start
Russia has put everything on the line to
pull ahead in this race and so far it's
really paying off alone at this point
even China who doesn't have its own
Arctic territory is way ahead of
America's efforts making this a race the
US cannot afford to sit out
the Arctic is melting because of climate
change but there's a lot more to climate
change than meets the eye climate change
is for sure happening but for an issue
that's supposedly about the survival of
the species there seems to be an awful
lot of power games and profiteering
involved take algor for example Al Gore
is a genius he used his position as vice
president to push the global warming
narrative he got everyone all scared he
got the government all scared and
willing to fund the fight against global
warming and then what did he do he
started a hedge fund a hedge fund called
generation Investment Management wow
what a noble sounding cause it's a hedge
fund that invests in what do you know
renewable technology how did this hedge
fund work out for him well in 2017 he
was worth an estimated 200 million
dollars that's because over the past 10
years the total Roi on renewable energy
has been 367 percent higher than fossil
fuels Al Gore created the problem and he
offered the perfect solution on a silver
platter his hedge fund and there are
many other profiteer in this world of
climate change just like Al Gore like
how climate change seems to be a great
excuse for rich countries to keep poor
countries poorer however we can't talk
about any of this in a public video
because this is one of the most dicey
topics on YouTube
so we just released a private
documentary on climate change narrated
by me a private documentary that I'm
still legitimately scared might get
taken down because although it does
conform with all of YouTube's Community
guidelines it's still extremely spicy
and controversial seriously guys this
one is good and you can watch it right
now by clicking that join button below
by joining you'll get access to this
documentary and other ones every month
that really are too controversial to be
released publicly the average college
course costs over eleven hundred dollars
and what do you learn nothing you leave
the class in debt and you're still
clueless about how the world really
works but with this you get all this
knowledge on how the world really works
for just five dollars a month so hit
that join button below and enjoy one of
our most controversial documentaries yet
I promise you won't regret it how
serious is my promise well there's a one
month refund policy unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within the
first month of joining for the first
time and we will personally refund you
for your first month after your first
month or there is no refund scroll down
and click that join button now
[Music]
[Music]